hey guys this is andrew for choosing
sensors.com so in this video i want to
talk about the dx5 the us dollar index
also going to talk about the euro dollar
pair
and see what my views are for the
beginning of 2021
let's get into it
[Music]
so the dxy for those who saw my previous
video i was basically saying that we
have
for the past five years we are trading
here between
88 and 103. i
spotted that we have here a descending
match pattern just as we had
here a few years ago all right and i was
saying that history repeats itself
that's
what i usually see so what i'm expecting
here
either we're going to break it on the
downside which is possible because the
fed is still printing a lot of money
uh there was the 900 billion us dollar
new stimulus plan
all right so to you know give all this
money to american people they need to
print money that's what they do
this is making the dollar weaker so
maybe we're gonna break it but anyways
guys we're not gonna break
such a strong level like this this is
not how things happen all right
what's might happen is that we have this
kind of consolidation that is going to
play out here
something like this guys all right
you see stuff like this and then i don't
know if we're gonna break it on the
upside on the or the downside i think a
break on the upside makes more sense
because the market is extended
and i see a correction coming coming
soon so
this goes together with a rush for the
dollar as i explained before all right
because people need us dollar to pay
back the debts
so they're gonna go for it if things
start to be
shaky even bloody so keep an eye on this
one this is as i said before a leading
indicator
uh so for now you can see that the wedge
pattern is perfectly respected let me go
to the four hours time frame
so here i was saying that we have a
descending batch pattern and that we
might have some
sort of consolidation here and yes look
it acted as support here
uh if you buy this level you can make
some profits between here and here
now it tested it again we still go you
know
it acts like support but we still
grinding lower
and i think that we might eventually
converge to the 88.5
level something like this all right and
of course i'm checking if we are
breaking this on the upside if yes guys
time to sell equity all right
this is how those two uh instruments are
linked you s p 500 and uh and dxy
have inverted correlation all right very
quickly the euro dollar pair
so same thing i did that again before
uh i'm just gonna check where we are
right now
so i was bullish here uh the reason why
i was bullish is because we are breaking
here
this resistance level that is like you
know a very long-term resistance level
downward sloping trend line
that we broke here we tested at 116 118
you know something like this
um and since then we are just uh going
higher
all right guys and i was saying that my
target for this is
uh 125 126 something like like this all
right
so this means that there is still
like around two percent move up to come
in this market
uh which is kind of uh you know goes
together with this where i can see
maximum you know 1.5 move
down so it won't happen right now you
know
it might happen around you know
march feb march something like this i
don't know and yeah so
uh resistance at 125 126 support level i
think we are going to retest
this level as well guys the 118 level
120 something like this
is probably gonna uh be trading around
feb feb march all right i don't know
exactly something like this
and then it's gonna be a big question
for the market are we gonna have a
strong rebound in the equity because the
correction would happen
i think uh around this um this timing is
gonna be even more bloody and all these
questions are gonna tell us
where the euro dollar is going where the
dxy is going and also where the bitcoin
is going i did a video on this one
not long ago and all this stuff goes
together
guys so keep in mind that the euro
dollar is still bullish with resistance
125 126
support level 116 118 and dxy
support level 88 89 and resistance 91
that's it for me guys stay close to
shore